الصين والهند شهدتان مناوشات حدوديه خلال
العقود الاخيره على طول منطقه الهملايا
ذات الاهميه الاستراتيجيه عام
1959 وقع اول نزاع حدودي بين الجانبين
خلال زياره رئيس وزراء الهند جواهر لالين
الى بيجين حيث شكك في الحدود الموضحه على
الخرائط الصينيه الرسميه عام
1962 وقعت الحرب الصينيه الهنديه واستمرت
شهرا مخلفه الاف القتلى على الجانب الهندي
بينما تحفظت الصين على عدد ضحاياها
عام
1967 وقعت بين الجانبين مناوشات ناتولا
وهو ممر جبلي شمل شرقي الهند قتل فيها 80
جنديا هنديا وجرح 400 جندي صيني
عام
1975 تعرض اربعه جنود هنود لكمين وقتلوا
على الحدود على الخط الحدودي في اورنتشيل
براديش عام 2017 وقعت مناوشات لشهور بهضبه
دوكلام الاستراتيجيه اثر اعتراض الهند على
انشاء الصين طريقا فى المنطقه الحدوديه
في عام 2020 اعلنت نيودلهي مصرع 20 جنديا
من جنودها على الحدود في ولايه سكيم
واتهمت القوات الصينيه بالتوغل عبر خط
الترسيم وفي العام الماضي اشتبك المئات من
الجنود الصينيين والهنود دون وقوع قتل على
الحدود المتنازع عليها شمال الهند